there has been a terror attack
in the aftermath the stunned calm on
westminster bridge
a passerby capturing the moments after
the murderous car journey before
emergency services arrived
pedestrians and cyclists targeted by the
killer
treated and comforted on the ground
eyewitnesses to the carnage console each
other
some break the news on their phones
others clearly distraught
little surprise after witnessing scenes
like this
one victim lying under the wheels of a
bus
a dreadful attack just meters from the
heart of britain's democracy
prompting defiance from the prime
minister the values our parliament
represents
democracy freedom human rights
the rule of law command the admiration
and respect
of free people everywhere
that is why it is a target for those who
reject those values
but let me make it clear today as i have
had cause to do
before any attempt to defeat those
values through violence and terror
is doomed to failure
this is how it began
[Applause]
confusion and panic as gunshots rang in
parliament square
you can see that we're being pushed back
by police at the moment
we came down here about four or five
minutes ago and there was a wave of
people running down the street including
workmen and others who work around
parliament who just said they didn't
know what was going on
but they heard a noise and they were
told just to get out as quickly as
possible
and this is where the car ended its
bloody mission smashed into the railings
the attacker on foot then forced his way
into new palace yard
where he stabbed a police officer in
front of horrified onlookers
just outside westminster underground
station
when i heard an almighty crash
and a vehicle looked like a 4x4
i could see on the opposite side of the
road it crashed into the railings there
was smoke
coming from underneath the bonnet of
this vehicle i walked on a few places
further
and saw what i assumed to be either a
pedestrian or a cyclist who'd clearly
been hit
and wasn't moving although he did then
gently move uh for a couple of seconds
the guy who i assume was the driver of
this 4x4
got out of the car and suddenly sprinted
away from the scene and that was
followed by
for what sounded very much like gunshots
to me
the attacker was shot by colleagues of
the injured officer
the suspect then taken away on a
stretcher stripped
his wounds covered the red circles mark
two knives
lying on the cobbles on a busy day in
parliament the prime minister and
hundreds of mps and staff were inside
the palace
back is he coming
back back back back
get back get back get back
get back somebody's under fire
counter terrorism specialist firearm
officers the elite response team
raced inside the prime minister
extracted
and removed at speed in her wake
thousands of confused tourists workers
and commuters
caught up in a few frantic moments at
one of the world's most famous landmarks
i was just walking across the bridge
when suddenly a bus stopped right in
front of me and everybody started
screaming um and i saw a trainer in the
road and first of all
i trained her as an issue a shoe yeah
and i thought somebody must have been
hit by a car
and then i saw a body on the other side
of the road and then there was another
body
further up and then when i looked over
the side of the bridge there was another
body
lying in the water parliament square
became a helipad
bringing armed officers in as ground
ambulances took the injured to nearby
saint thomas's hospital
inside parliament two hours after prime
minister's questions a clerk
ran into the chamber with the news this
step i am now going to suspend the
sitting of the house
this house is no suspended but please
wait here
mps and parliamentary staff gathered in
central lobby where an armed officer
struck an incongruous figure
they filled ancient westminster hall
checking their phones for information
as the lockdown continued one mp was
caught in the crash
outside on the palace perimeter we had
no choice but to leave the building
and we have um rotary doors one in one
out at a time so people getting stuck in
the doors
there was a real sense of panic at that
point as we all tried to get out of the
doors
and um i shouted to the security guard
to open the door so we could all just
leave as quickly as possible
he was a bit reluctant to do that
because i think they'd already been told
that they were on lockdown and to keep
things shut
but obviously we wanted to get out of
that situation where there was shooting
behind us
as quickly as possible across the river
the london eye stopped turning
tourists trapped in the glass pods as
the discordant chorus of sirens
continued on the ground
new scotland yard is a few hundred
meters from the scene
officers brought to the grim updates one
of those who died today was a police
officer
pc keith palmer a member of our
parliamentary and diplomatic protection
command
keith age 48 had 15-year service and was
a husband and father
he was someone who left for work today
expecting to return home at the end of
his shift
and he had every right to expect that
would happen i can also now confirm that
there are three members of the public
who've lost their lives in the attack
especially trained family supporters
family liaison officers have been
deployed to support them
and as i confirmed earlier the suspected
attacker was shot dead
by an armed officer therefore meaning
that now in total we have five people
who've died today
armed with a car and knives in a few
minutes one man ended lives
and wrought horrific injuries the day
the capital's emergency services feared
finally arrived robert nisbet sky news
westminster